Let’s say you’re visiting Earth for the
first time.
And the tour of the planet consists of being
dropped into random locations for about five
seconds before being whisked away to an entirely
different spot on the globe.
If you knew nothing whatsoever about life
on Earth, how might you interpret what you
saw?
At first, these narrow glimpses of a vast
world would be confusing, and probably a little
bizarre.
But over time, as the brief snapshots formed
a greater whole — you might be able to get
a sense of broader patterns of life here on
Earth.
‘Exobiotica’ is a speculative biology
project by incredible artist Michael Beaudry
that offers similarly limited windows into
the sprawling alien biosphere of a planet
called Veteris.
In the words of the artist, “Each composition
is a tip of an iceberg – a momentary and
fleeting glimpse into an entire ecosystem.”
And the lifeforms we can document are uniquely
alien — even by the standards of speculative
biology.
Yet the more art you observe, the more you
begin to understand the larger stories of
life upon Planet Veteris.
So, for this entry into the Archive, we’ll
shine a light on the secrets of each region
— and uncover how the larger ecosystems
fit together.
And as always, you can follow and support
the artist using the links in the description.
Now, let’s set off towards Planet Veteris,
and prepare for our first glimpse of this
world of mysteries.
Planet Veteris lies beyond the outskirts of
a stunning nebula.
The very name — ‘Veteris’ – gives
us some understanding of the nature of this
world, as it means ‘Ancient’ in Latin.
And indeed, this planet is quite old relative
to Earth — at almost eight-billion years.
Since this is nearly twice the age of our
home planet, there’s no telling what life
has emerged.
Time for a closer look…
Touching down on Veteris, our first glimpse
of the teeming surface is difficult to comprehend.
At a glance, it’s hard to tell which of
these organisms are plants, and which are
animals.
On Earth, broad categories like plants, animals,
and fungi are useful in the classification
of lifeforms, and it’s rare that one would
mistake one for the other.
But the lifeforms on Veteris resist such classifications
entirely, and many remain unnamed.
The large, plodding walkers move like animals,
yet they can photosynthesize.
The flower-like lifeforms might look like
plants, but they can ‘walk’ on their spindly
legs.
The long, rope-like organisms that carpet
the ground can’t walk, but do grow at a
rapid pace to mark their territory.
Even the rock-like spheres are secretly alert,
employing an electro-chemical defense to keep
the creeping tendrils at bay.
The end result is an ecosystem with extreme
biodiversity that is truly difficult for us
Earthlings to comprehend.
But the more locations we visit, the more
we’ll understand.
The twisting matrix of tendrils define a region
known as the Low Forest, and here we’ll
discover another unusual organism roaming
amidst the strands.
This is a Dacia — a generalist hunter that
walks upon three flexible hydraulic legs,
which are powered by pressured liquid.
An organism powering their legs with hydraulics
might sound like pure sci-fi, yet surprisingly,
many types of Arachnids actually use pressured
liquid to help power their spindly legs.
And since Veteris’s gravity is lesser than
Earth’s, we’ll find many organisms get
around on similar hydraulic tubes.
Aside from its locomotive limbs, the Dacia
posses small grasping appendages to help it
apprehend prey and communicate with other
members of its species.
For the Dacia is a fairly clever and naturally
curious lifeform… which can sometimes lead
it into trouble.
For the most part, Dacias stick to the Low
Forest when searching for food.
In our next snapshot, however, we can see
a Dacia standing at the threshold of a very
different kind of environment.
An organic cave marks the entrance to the
otherwise sealed Glow Forest.
Encouraged by the prospect of shelter, the
Dacia considers entering the dark, yet inviting
refuge.
But what will it find inside…
Entering another snapshot, we can see that
within the Glow Forest, a mysterious ecosystem
awaits.
Since this region possesses such a thick canopy,
virtually no light reaches lifeforms that
dwell within.
As a result, these organisms have evolved
a startling array of bioluminescent displays.
On Earth, surreal pageants of bioluminescence
can be found throughout the depths of the
oceans.
These remarkable spectacles of light are thought
to serve a variety of functions — from communicating,
to attracting prey, to warding off predators.
And in the Glow Forest, the mysterious displays
are equally diverse.
This particular organism possesses glowing
bands on its back, likely to attract a mate.
The vibrant colors and slug-like locomotive
appendages of this lifeform call to mind certain
genera of marine gastropods.
And with a sharp, stinger-like protrusion
on its front end, this doesn’t seem like
a particularly friendly customer…
Closer to the forest floor, vertical glowing
bulbs sprout from the ground in vast quantities.
The vibrant light they’re emitting indicates
these bulbs are on the cusp of reproducing...
but they might never get the chance.
For they are under siege by a slow-moving,
yet ever-hungry behemoth — a Laterna Pulmonis.
Although a placid, rather unintelligent sort
of fellow, this organism is nonetheless a
serious threat to the glowing bulbs.
Like its food source, the Laterna Pulmonis
possess purple biolumescence, which helps
it blend into the surrounding forest.
So, unless a very sharp-eyed predator comes
along, the Laterna Pulmonis will likely continue
its snacking...
In the murky ponds on the floor of the Glow
Forest, we can glimpse a surprisingly diverse
community of organisms that thrive in these
cloudy pools.
A miniature forest of towering colonial microorganisms
dominates the landscape, feeding off of methane
gas released by decaying organic matter.
Upon this bedrock of the food chain, a plethora
of creatures creep and crawl about their daily
lives.
On our planet, similar dramas unfold in coastal
rock pools.
And while these pools might seem peaceful,
they are actually battlegrounds for survival.
Predators like the starfish are constantly
on the prowl — and they in turn are sometimes
swallowed up by certain sea anemones, which
grow large enough to consume almost anything
in the pool.
And on Veritis, a similarly ravenous goliath
terrorizes the murky ponds.
In the distance, the pond’s top predator
rises over the towers — a shadowy leviathan
that devours everything in its path.
Other creatures need to keep their distance.
Far from the dimness of the Glow Forest, our
next snapshot brings us to the vast plains.
Here, we can see a group of spindly lifeforms
called the Magnavindix engaging in a very
intriguing behavior.
These imposing creatures, which stand around
fifteen feet, or four meters in height, are
shepherds of sorts, keeping watch over their
unusual flock.
They spend their days herding the placid,
defenseless Lumentus that are their main source
of food.
On Earth, several species of ants are known
to engage in a similar behavior.
These ants are herding aphids — small rotund
insects that excrete a sugary liquid the ants
feed on.
In exchange, the ants go to great lengths
to care for their wards, protecting them from
predators, carrying them to new pasture lands
to feed, and even encouraging them to reproduce.
And the Magnavindix are similarly involved
in the lives of the Lumentus, playing the
role of both defender and matchmaker, bringing
pairs of Lumentus together when their bio-lights
signal they’re ready to mate.
Indeed, this symbiosis has grown to the point
where the Lumentus have no conception of danger,
and are free to grow heavy and slow as they
graze upon the expanse of fibrous purple organisms
that dominate this land…
Looking through another window, on Veteris,
it seems symbiosis has emerged in other unexpected
formulations.
This spherical lifeform is a Round-Walker,
and while it might not look particularly mobile,
it does, in fact, amble slowly on its long
spindly legs.
At the moment, this particular Round Walker
is beleaguered by a flock of flat parasites
clinging to its surface.
Yet the Round Walker isn’t bothered, for
its surface is tended to by a spiny little
fellow called a Guardian.
Like their name suggests, Guardians are the
defenders of the Round-Walkers, as well as
their cleaning service — and in exchange,
the Round-Walkers serve as their living homes.
This mutualistic symbiosis has converged on
a partnership similar to that of sea anemones
and clownfish.
Certain anemones rely on clownfish heavily
— as clownfish both keep the anemone clean,
provide nutrients in the form of waste, and
scare off any would-be pillagers.
In return, the anemone’s tentacles provide
a safe home for the tiny clownfish.
The Guardians and Round-Walkers are similarly
linked, to the point where you’ll never
find either species on their own.
And so, the Round Walkers amble along, each
crowned by a spiny guardian defending their
small world.
Not all organisms are so harmonious.
Deep within a forested valley, a familiar
arms-race has emerged in some very unfamiliar
lifeforms.
Here, a predatory creature called the Veloxos
follows its hunting path by the river.
It’s a capable hunter, with three powerful
hydraulic legs and a harpoon-like proboscis,
which extends almost to the full length of
its body.
And this Veloxos has spotted its prey — a
Dish-Faced Septaped that emerged from the
undergrowth for a drink.
The Septaped’s appearance helps it blend
in among inactive lifeforms on the forest
floor — much like how Earth’s Bargibant's
seahorses have evolved to almost perfectly
resemble the sessile stalks of coral.
But like the specialized seahorse, the Septaped’s
camouflage only works for specific environments,
and in this light, it’s dangerously exposed.
Moments from now, an intense chase will begin
between predator and prey.
No matter which species triumphs, the perpetual
theater of natural selection will continue
all across the planet.
Natural selection doesn’t just breed competition
on land, however.
Our next glimpse shows us a scene below the
waves of this alien world.
Here, the quick and nimble Seaswifts jet along
the current, sporting long, lateral spikes
to keep predators at bay.
Spikes are a common defense in the natural
world, with certain types of marine gastropods
having converged on similar lateral defenses.
Near the spikey Seaswifts, the more vulnerable
Bubble Swimmers drift along.
These filter-feeders use wave-like ripples
in their translucent outer membrane to propel
themselves slowly through the current.
Both the Seaswifts and the Bubble Swimmers
are on their own in the vast oceans…
But other species have partnered up.
The Glass Colligatio is a composite organism
— a creature composed of multiple species
that share critical biological processes between
them.
In the Glass Colligatio’s case, the larger
swimmer provides mobility, while its multi-legged
symbiont feeds more effectively than it could
alone.
As discussed before on this channel, numerous
organisms on Earth are also comprised of multiple
lifeforms working in tandem to survive.
Yet curiously, interdependence between two
separate species appears far more common on
Veteris than on Earth — a trend that will
only strengthen the more lifeforms we observe.
Near the surface of this world’s oceans,
one can — on rare occasions — catch a
glimpse of a bizarre display.
An entourage of deep-sea behemoths are making
a brief ascent to the surface, releasing gelatinous
strings of embryos here in the sunlight where
their young will have better visibility upon
hatching.
While a lifeform blindly releasing huge clouds
of their children into the wild might sound
like a bad strategy, it mirrors that of many
lifeforms on Earth.
In general, there are two main reproductive
strategies on our planet.
Organisms that are K-strategists produce fewer
young, but place a greater investment in each,
ensuring a higher percentage of their children
reach adulthood.
But there are also R-strategists — which
flood the ecosystem with progeny so that regardless
of how many don’t make it, at least some
are likely to survive long enough to reproduce.
While the behemoths are clearly R-strategists
— their children won’t be completely on
their own.
A swarm of intrigued lifeforms tail the behemoths,
and will become unwitting hosts for their
multitudinous offspring.
The embryos will stick to and develop upon
the surface of these surrogate species, until
they’re ready to hatch.
Luckily for the host species, however, they
won’t suffer any ill effects from their
temporary parasites…
In the murky blackness of the deep sea, many
creatures use bioluminescence similar to the
lifeforms of the Glow Forest.
The amusingly-named Gullible Vagari wander
the depths looking for the matching biolight
of another member of its species.
Described as a hopeless romantic, whether
the Vagari’s search ends in success or tragedy
is a matter of fate.
For there is dangerous predator skulking in
the abyss.
The Giant Allicio is an organism that has
evolved bioluminescent appendages that mimic
the light of the Vagari — its main food
source — and lure them into its jaws.
This low-energy hunting method has resulted
in a cumbersome lifeform that isn’t particularly
hydrodynamic.
On Earth, the lumpy Frogfish have a similarly
ungainly body plan due to a convergent lifestyle.
Like the Giant Allicio, the Frogfish baits
its prey with a specialized lure on the front
of its head.
After all, when your food comes to, you don’t
have to be particularly mobile…
Back on land, a lifeform known as The Sunworshipper
leads a placid and cautious existence high
above the ground.
Like many other mobile creatures on Veteris,
The Sunworshipper receives a portion of its
energy from photosynthesis - as evidenced
by the specially-adapted appendages radiating
from its body.
To stay safe, the sunworshipper has evolved
‘eyespots’ on its appendages — which
give predators the impression of a much more
formidable opponent.
This sort of defensive mimicry is convergent
with various Earth prey animals, perhaps most
notably the eye-spots on the wings of certain
types of butterflies.
For a creature that wants to stay hidden,
the coloration of the Veteris might seem strange
or even gaudy by our terrestrial standards,
but in its native habitat the bright red serves
as excellent camouflage.
And in a world as extreme as Veteris, it pays
to blend in…
Our second to last glimpse at Planet Veteris
is one of the most striking.
Here, the ruler of a misty valley watches
as a competitor makes their approach.
These lifeforms are Greater Confo, highly
territorial organisms that do battle with
as set of forward-facing hydraulic spears.
This disputed territory is a surreal landscape
of fluid filled branching grows called Camcenas,
a type of photosynthetic lifeform.
And this biome has hidden dangers.
The glowing orange gel that coats the forest
floor is both tasty and extremely sticky,
designed to ensnare hungry lifeforms that
will later be consumed.
A flock of Bicolor Micans have noticed this
accumulation, are flying en masse to take
advantage of it – carefully.
For even a creature as large as the invading
Confo might become trapped if it’s not vigilant…
And in our last image, we can see a scene
where seasonal rains have blessed an arid
region.
Here, Desert Runners — lifeforms with now
familiar tripodal body plans — congregate
for a drink.
But the allure of water has drawn in another
organism as well — the unparalleled Monolith.
These living towers send thick tendrils towards
the shallow pools to drink their fill.
The monolith may only get the chance to drink
in this way two or three times a year, but
it’s enough to keep the structure alive
during drier periods.
And along the surface of the Monolith, glowing
biolights shimmer in the setting sun.
These points of light are signals to the Nox
that soar nearby — fliers that root within
the Monolith during the day, and in return
provide the structure with discarded food.
Each Nox can recognize the unique pattern
of biolights on their home monolith out of
the crowd of others.
This final example of symbiosis may have been
a surprise at the beginning of our journey,
but now, it’s just another familiar expression
of Planet Veteris’s broader patterns…
Like an alien visiting witnessing Earth’s
splendor in brief snapshots, our understanding
of Planet Veteris will always be somewhat
limited, but we’ve now observed enough moments
across the planet’s surface to understand
many of its fascinating systems.
It’s been a unique viewing experience, and
there may be more to come.
According to the creator, the larger ‘Exobiotica’
project will eventually cover other planets
beyond the world of Veteris, that will harbor
entirely new forms of life.
But for now, if you enjoyed discovering the
secrets of Michael Beaudry’s incredible
compositions, you can once again follow and
support the artist to see more exciting illustrations
using the links in the description.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support and like, subscribe, and hit the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things Curious.
See you in the next video.